was always said that the Conservatives
were the party of business of the
strivers and the risk takers but you
could be forgiven for thinking a few of
the proposals they're kicking around
through next month's budget wouldn't
look out of place in a Corbin manifesto
talk this week turned to the potential
scrapping of entrepreneurs relief a
reduced rate of capital gains tax which
basically allows our entrepreneurs to
sell their business and pay a rate of
just ten percent of gains up to ten
million pounds
faced with criticism from the very
entrepreneurs the party is said to
represent Sajid Javid is now looking at
what to do with it from reducing the
limits who's stopping altogether for new
businesses but this attitude is wrong
entrepreneurs are the lifeblood of the
economy they take risks they pump money
in and they create jobs
the Tories should be looking at ways to
incentivize the more not less well as we
try to explain these business owners can
qualify for entrepreneurs relief under
which they can pay just ten percent
capital gains tax when they sell all or
part of the company compared to the
standard capital gains tax rate of 20%
this compares with what you forty or
forty five percent if you are really
taught by tax payer I have never
understood the capital gains tax used to
be paid at the same rate is whatever the
arresting your tax was paid out and I
always thought that was perfectly
rational
I don't see why necessarily you should
pay less tax on money you've earned
you've earned by investing than you do
by working in fact I think probably it
should be the other way around
I've used entrepreneurs the truth is
that people will always try to minimize
their tax that's natural that's natural
but I'm not sure that I think there's
quite a good quote I think you've said
it better than the probably I can cite
from the former head of the HMRC Sir
Edward troop who said the point of on
entrepreneurs relief is that it would
you when you make a lot of money there
are lots of things getting in the way of
people becoming great entrepreneurs in
this country but the fear of tax on
future gains is not one of them and
that's my but I don't see anyone
starting a business it's going to be
worried about what they're gonna sell it
for how much taxes are gonna play in
five or ten years time it's not about
the percentage it's about the principle
we're in a post brexit world soon to be
we need to be doing everything possible
to encourage and you say well what's the
difference between regular tax and say
this title I would say risk and reward
if I go for a salary job only encourage
people to try and flog their companies
as soon as they can to the person who's
going to pay them much in cash I I did
it costs HMRC 2.7 billion pounds by this
start I keep hearing this oh it costs
the HMRC all this money over these years
that's nonsense what you're saying is
you're assuming if you increase the rate
or reduce the threshold the euro then
assuming that you would get the same
taxes yeah but I can ask the wrong
assumption because what people would do
so they then think oh and I can sell it
and I'll only pay 10% on my capital gain
if I'm lucky enough to have it they
might not sit there today and go I know
what I'm gonna do in order to get 10%
tax let's set up a business because that
would be a bit silly but when you're
looking at your exit strategy or your
pension strategy or whatever it is
absolutely or started and is now gonna
be stopped
severely reduced by a Conservative
government Alec I think in the corporate
and tax world my kind of concerns the
layperson would be you know we're
dealing with post break so we've got a
flu virus which is causing a lot of
issues and you know there's concerns we
might go into a recession I understand
this quantitative easing going the
economy as well and we don't want to do
anything that's going to kind of rock
the boat that'd be my concern
I'm genuinely think this is the cherry
on top of the cake for a great why Gregg
often talks about how our media industry
has been sold to the Americans started a
company to a certain things is making
staggeringly rich people get even richer
and the stats on wealth inequality at
the moment are are really quite
staggering so let's just quickly have a
look at them in the wealth of the top
ten richest people rose by seven hundred
thousand between 2010 and 2012 the
wealth of the poorest ten people in the
UK dropped by a hundred ten people
dropped by 100 pounds people that you're
saying they're losing their wealth I
want to get those people and I want to
incentivize them to if they choose to
create a business to create wealth and
what I want as a country I want our
attitude and our outlook especially
first brexit to be one of calm here we
are a great place to do business we are
a great place itself your businesses and
invest in your businesses so I want the
principle to be more encouraging of
entrepreneurship this figure from the
note six hundred and sixty thousand new
companies registered in the UK every
year that's
70 new businesses being formed each
normal tax they pay what about capital
gains tax it's this idea that because
when you work really hard and you earn
over 150 grand or whatever it is a year
you're paying 45 percent tax on taking
that money why did you only pay 20% tax
and make you can also sell your equity
your stocks and shares in companies and
only be taxed 10 percent under the same
system is that fair I don't think it is
there are qualifications that you have
to be a director all you have to have
work you have to be an employee anyway
let's look at a head of tax at more
Kingston Smith and Tim Stover let's say
what he has to say this country needs is
risk takers it needs people to be
aspirational to innovate we need people
to think creatively to build the future
facing businesses this country must have
to provide good jobs for young people
and to deliver a secure tax base for
these things to happen the support of
the tax system is of fundamental
importance it's been claimed that
entrepreneurs relief exists to make the
rich staggeringly rich but the much
derided lifetime allowance of 10 million
is giving entrepreneurs something to
shoot for something to dream about in
the long lean years in reality the
average claim is closer to half a
million I agree with him only half a
million employee employed as you know
attending everything appearing in the
Evening Standard every night some people
are out there grafting setting up
businesses Rachel that's what you need
to learn